welcome to our 2021
lab roots series my name is leah lavery
marketing manager for life science
electron microscopy from thermo fisher
scientific
and your moderator today this is the
third webinar in our series and
we welcome back any returning attendees
and a big hello to new attendees
wherever you are in the world many of
you know thermo fisher from other life
science areas
but i want to introduce you to the life
science electron microscopy division
our materials and structural analysis
division provides complete workflows
from cryo-electron
microscopy structural determination of
macro-liquid complexes
to 3-d reconstruction of tissues and
cells
cellular cryo-electron tomography is a
high-resolution technique
that enables electron imaging of the
molecular machining of a cell
at close to native conditions today our
speaker
alex rigert will be sharing how cryo
electron tomography is applied to answer
various biological questions and how the
workflow can be combined
with fluorescence imaging in one
microscope for correlative microscopy
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
alex presentation today is titled turn
on the lights with cryofib tomography
sample preparation alex works as a
product marketing manager for thermo
fisher scientific
he developed and used cryo-focused ion
beam instrumentation
for applications in electron tomography
at the max planck's institute for
biochemistry in munich
has more than 15 years experience in
cryo-electron microscopy
alex we look forward to your
presentation please
be in
yeah thanks very much leah for the
introduction also from
my site welcome to this webinar
let me start with an overview about the
two main imaging methods in chi oem
so this is single particle analysis and
cryotomography
in single particle analysis we basically
study isolated proteins
at a very high resolution why we want to
look at
the protein function in cells with
cryotomography
now there's actually a good reason why
we want to study proteins in their
natural cellular context
that's basically most proteins are not
existing
in isolation so they form multi-protein
complexes or so-called macromolecular
machines
and the only technique to study these
complexes within the context of the cell
is actually tomography
now before we can apply cryotomography
we need to
prepare our specimens and freeze them
and we have to do that in a very fast
way so that's why we rely on
so-called vitrification methods here
vitrification is a
rapid freezing process that avoids that
ice crystals can form during the
freezing process in the cells
these ice crystals would interfere with
the hydrostructure and the imaging
later on so that's why we need to avoid
them so instead of
slow freezing vitrification is a very
fast freezing process that
embeds the samples in the so-called
amorphous eyes
there are two techniques available for
achieving this one is shown here on the
left side it's called bunch freezing or
thin film verification so that can
vitrify samples up to a sequences of
five
microns anything that is thicker
and you can think here of some small
organisms or some
tissue biopsies or for instance some
organoids
those would need to go into a different
device which is called a high pressure
freezer
and the technique is called high
pressure freezing this can achieve
vitrification thicknesses up to 200
micrometers so these are basically the
two methods to create
petrified specimens for cryo microscopy
tomography can be done on different
types of samples this is what is shown
on
this slide here there are different
levels of complexity that come along
with this
different sample types if you look here
at the
left side so we look at samples such as
isolated proteins or virus particles
that's conceptually the same sample
preparation
as you would do it for single particle
analysis but then if we go here
to the right you can see the increa the
level of
complexity basically increases and that
also brings certain challenges with it
so
on one hand there is a difficulty in
localizing the region of interest
the more sick the sample gets and it's
already a challenge
to localize regions inside cells
but also there are different challenges
coming on the preparative side so that
implies the use for instance of a
focused ion beam to make the samples
accessible for tomography to make the
samples transparent for tomography
and in terms of high pressure freezing
you see that that has probably the most
complex
requirements it's not only a challenge
to localize the region
of interest it requires a different
freezing technique
high pressure freezing it requires a
focused iron beam
to excavate regions of interest and on
top of that it also requires a lift out
device
where we can basically excise the
regions of interest
to bring them to a crit to make them
accessible for tomography
let's take a look in this small
animation how we prepare ourselves
on grids for electron tomography so the
preparation starts typically with the
cells that are in a petri dish
from the from the culture lab you take
that
dish and go to a vitro body by so this
is a
plunge freezing device the cells will be
localized
on top of an electron microscopy grid
they are typically embedded in a small
thin layer of
buffer solution or media that has to be
plotted before the plunging process
so by this plotting step we can create
basically a thin film that's why the
method is also called
thin film vitrification the criticism
rapidly immersed into a secondary
cryogen
so that's a liquid ethane here and this
is basically the step
when we have created a vitified sample
on top of the kit
so with this grid we can now proceed in
the workflow
for cryotomography now once you have
vitrified the cells
you can take them to the cryotem in the
cryotm you would probably see an image
like shown on this slide it shows a cell
on the grid
and you can clearly see here for
instance the cell membrane
and also peripheral regions of the cell
so these are regions which are electron
transparent but you can also notice the
problem so as soon as we go
more towards the center of the cell and
you may notice here a phabosomal
compartment
then one thing you see is that the
signature noise drops
quite significantly so that means at
some point the sample is simply not
electron transparent anymore
so that's why we need to go to a
different instrument before
and this is a focused imbeam instrument
which can create
electron transparent samples from such
objects
on grids and i will show you how that
works in the next slide
so this slide shows you our aquidos 2
cryofib system
this is a dedicated device for preparing
samples for electron tomography
and it's a dual beam instrument so dual
beam instrument means that there are two
columns on this system
one is an electron column for scanning
electron microscopy
and there's also a focused ion beam
column now the focused ion beam column
produces a very fine focus beam of
gallium ions that can be used to ablate
material from a cellular sample and the
way how that works is shown
in this little animation which we will
take a look at now
so here we go into the system uh this is
a cryo specimen so we load that on the
cryo stage we can use an electron beam
to image the sample
as you would do in a scanning electron
microscope and then we use the
ion beam that you can see here to
manipulate the sample and remove
areas of interest so the way this is
done how
the meta is created is shown here the
iron beam
removes material from the cell and what
is left behind then is a
lamellar which is still connected to the
sides of the the cell
so by this we can create a sample that
is electron transparent and which allows
us to take a look into the interior of a
frozen hydrated
cell
here's a real life example how cryofib
milling of cells on the grid
works um you can see here uh frozen
chlamydamona cells or green algae cells
and you can see in this
image here the yellow boxes which
indicates
the areas the ion beam is going to
remove
so you can easily recognize here these
are rather
thick objects which are non-electron
transparent
and what we are going to prepare from
this object is a sin
in z to the meta so after inb milling
the result looks like this you can see
the lamellar here
you can also see the areas where the ion
beam has removed
material and by this we have created now
an electron transparent lamellar in the
range of 200 300 nanometers
that can be transferred to the cryotem
for a tomography
experiment the image here on the right
side
shows you an overview of such a lamellar
in the cryotem
and you can see we created basically a
very large cross section
through the green algae cell which
reveals a lot of subcellular morphology
you can see the thylakoids system here
quite well you can see also the pyranoid
which is surrounded by starch
and you can see various subcellular
organelles in here
so there's plenty of room now to set up
a tomography experiment
on such a in z2 lamella
once such a lamellar has been created
the next step is to basically take it
out of the focused ion beam system
so that's what you can see in this small
movie here
and then transferred into a cryo tem
system
so this shows you the cryos g4 which is
a 300 kv
transmission electron microscope and the
actual tomography
tilt series is acquired in that
instrument you can see that here
so we basically rotate the sample under
the electron beam
and what that produces is a so-called
projection series
from that projection series we can
reconstruct
tomogram and that tomogram reveals then
uh basically a snapshot of the frozen
hydrated cellular interior in this case
showing here
golgi with surrounding ribosomes and
for instance also the nuclear core so
this gives you detailed
information about the interior of cells
at a very high resolution
the quality of cryo-electron tomography
data is quite important especially when
it comes to subsequent image processing
steps
so on the left side here you can see an
image from a tomogram and you can see
the
the structures of individual ribosomes
those have been obtained by a
subtomogram averaging
technique so
it's very important to have good
contrast for this technique
and this can come from an energy filter
the energy filter
is basically a device that is able to
filter out the inelastically
scattered electrons from the images and
thereby preserving to more
high resolution information in the
original images
so this slide shows you data that has
been obtained with our synactus energy
filter
you can see a tomogram here which shows
individual vesicles that are budding off
from the golgi complex
you may also see here quite nicely the
individual proteins that are lining the
surface of these
vesicles you can also see in tomography
dynamic processes such as the
formation the budding off of such a
vesicle from the golgi
so that can be studied only if we have a
decent
image data quality and for this the
energy filter is a quite essential
device
because it can boost the contrast and
preserve more
high frequency information in the images
after this introduction into
cryotomography i would actually like to
come back to the aquidos 2 cryofib
system
and show you the current state of the
art of this cryofib system
so the slide here shows your overview
cross section schematic of the system
with all
relevant cryo features
central to a kyofib system is the
capability to
cool the stage and keep the stage cool
so we have at the center of the system
here
a cryo stage this is a rotatable cryo
stage
which is kept at -170 minus 180 degrees
celsius temperature
it's a gas cooled stage so the gas for
that cooling comes from
nitrogen gas which is sent through a
heat exchanger in an offline
dewa and so the cool gas is then
basically
used to achieve the temperatures that
are required for cryo work
also important for a cryosystem is the
ability to load
samples into the system and then also
out of the system
uh later so this happens in an offline
loading station
so in the loading station samples which
are typically on the kit
as you saw that before are loaded into a
small cryo shuttle
this device basically holds the em grids
or the hpf
samples it's uh moved into a
transfer rod and then under vacuum
transfer to a load lock of the system
and once you've done the load lock cycle
you can push that sample onto the cryo
stage
and once this is done we can actually
start to work
with the beams on the sample there's
functionality such as an
integrated sputter coder it's important
to keep the samples
conductive or to apply conductive
platinum coatings
onto the samples or very thin coatings
there's also a gis system which is a gas
injection system
that is used to apply thick platinum
coatings so that are
so called protective coatings that help
with with the milling process
we have a device here which is a the
easy lift kyle this is a lift out
needle which allows you to do lift outs
as i shown before
for the high pressure frozen samples
and the latest add-on to the system
which i will also describe in more
detail
today this is an integrated light
microscope
which we can use to inspect fluorescence
inside this
system so that basically gives you an
overview of all the cryo-related
functionality
that comes with the aquidos 2 system
leaving the schematic now and this is an
image of the actual instrument
so you can see the aquidos 2 with all
its accessories on this image
on the right hand side you can see the
loading station where we load the cryo
specimens
into a transfer device which is attached
here to the load lock of the system
the clio stage is part of the high
vacuum chamber here
you can also see on the left hand side
of the system console
viewer so this is used to cool down the
gas
to maintain a code supply of gas for
cooling down the stage
also you can see on the left hand side
of the instrument
this is the retractable sputter coder
device
which is also part of the of darkriders2
system
there are also two optional components
visible here so
one is here on the front part the
easylift
micromanipulator system so that's a
liftout system that can be optionally
selected
for the system and what is new this year
and what i'm going to introduce
in the next slides this is a new
integrated light microscope so it's the
iflm correlative microscope
that we are introducing this year to the
aquilos ii system
so the aquas is a pretty complete system
for the processing
manipulation and imaging of child
specimens
and i listed the key main features of
that system on this slide here again
so that's around automation capabilities
for the lamellar production process
imaging capabilities slice and view
technique here
the capability to perform cryoliftout
with the micromanipulation device
and then the latest add-on to the system
the integrated light microscope
which i will go into details in the
upcoming slides
so let me first go into a bit uh
overview about the other features before
i'm coming back to the light microscope
the first feature i'd like to highlight
here are the automation capabilities of
the system
we have developed a special software for
doing this
software is called auto tem cryo so this
is a dedicated version of
the auto tem software which is around
for
for many years already in the dual beam
world
and this software allows you to
customize the milling patterns and
parameters and basically set up multiple
sites for automated milling
so the image on the right hand side
shows you a result of such a automation
run
so you can see here several sites that
have been selected before
and marked for for milling and then we
used auto term software basically
to carry out a automated
milling process and you can see here the
final results so these are all sites
that have been produced autonomously
with the help of autotemprio software
the software is quite flexible when it
comes to adapting
the parameters to the
to a given child sample so there's a
flexibility on selecting the milling
patterns there can be also
extra options added such as for instance
adding here relief cuts
to the lamella production process
and it's also possible with that
software to do
not only the course milling but also the
final polishing then
of the lamella so down to a thickness of
200
nanometers so with the help of that
software we can
and with the automation in general we
can increase of course the milling
throughput and efficiency and that's one
of the
big assets of an automation
software next feature i'd like to
highlight is
cryo slice and view software which is an
integral part of the aquidos 2 system
so this software allows you to
[Music]
to obtain 3d data like you can see in
this movie here on the right hand side
um it works by sequentially milling
and imaging the the cut surfaces with
the electron beam so i use the iron beam
to produce the cut surface then image
the surface with the electron beam and
by doing this in a sequential fashion
you can acquire a 3d volume you can see
that here
for such a kilometer mono cell where you
can nicely see the nucleus and the
different golgi complexes surrounding
the cell so this type of imaging gives
us
contextual information about the sample
it's not a high resolution as you would
get it from electron tomography
but again it can use or can be used to
basically guide the lamellar milling
process
it's particularly interesting to apply
that also in combination with
hypershafus samples
where you can use it to navigate where
you are in a rather complex by example
just based on the on the cryo contrast
signal that you see here
so the contrast which you see here this
is um secondary electron detection
and it's uh all based on uh charge based
imaging
so remember there's no stains which are
kind of
or heavy metal ions which are part of
this sample here it's just a pure
native frozen sample that we look at so
that kind of
is that information which slicing view
can give you from
such frozen cryo samples
i mentioned already in the beginning
when i spoke about the different sample
types that tomography can be
performed on so the more complex the
sample is the more
bulk it gets then at some point you
cannot avoid uh
to do a lift out the lift out basically
allows you to exercise a region
from a from a bike frozen specimen it
can be also done
for an on the grid specimen and to
basically lift out a small chunk of
cellular material
with that micro manipulator device and
then bring this little uh
chunk you can see that here in the
images below so this is a lamellar which
has been
prepared from such a sample uh this can
be
taken onto a lift out grit and then also
transferred to the tem for tomography so
that's the idea of the
liftout system we basically support both
use cases with our easy lift system
we can do lift outs from samples that
are grown on grids
so that enables some different milling
geometries compared to this
classical in z to the meta geometries
but the main purpose of course to
enable also the work on hpf samples so
the more bike cruising samples
where you really need to lift out to
excise material
so the whole easy lift micro manipulator
system is fully integrated into the
aquilas
ii system and again this is also
active development so we have already
best practice procedures developed
which also avoid for instance the use of
a gis system for the lift out
so that we can more routinely apply
lift out to frozen hydrated samples
yeah with this i like to introduce the
latest add-on to the aquidos ii cryofib
which is the iflm
correlative system the iflm stands for
an integrated fluorescence light
microscope
and that brings fluorescence imaging
capabilities
to the existing aquilos system
so it is now not only possible to do
electron and
ion beam imaging within the system but
we can also add
fluorescence imaging capabilities to the
same system
so coming back to the title of this
webinar
we can prepare a mello as you you saw
that before
and now with that new system we can turn
on the lights
with the help of the integrated light
microscope and see whether our
fluorescent targets are contained within
the produced lamella
so that is all possible now by
integrating a light microscope
into the existing aquidos 2 cryofib
the new option to do a correlative like
microscopy directly inside the aquilas 2
system
brings several advantages to the
cryotomography workflow
you can see that workflow on this slide
what you can also see here is that there
are a number of transfer steps
included in the workflow so from the
moment you freeze the sample
you will typically go to an external
light microscope
and from the external light microscope
into the cryofib system
and then again into the cryotem system
so these transfer steps always
bear the risk for contaminating the
samples
so by integrating the light microscope
into the cryofib system
we can eliminate one sample transfer
step
and thereby also reduce the transfer
contamination risks
by combining a light microscope with the
fib stem system we can also simplify
the electron to light correlation
by having two imaging modalities in
one system so this allows for a faster
retrieval of the regions of interest
and we can basically achieve a higher
throughput with that
there's another interesting option when
combining a light microscope with the
cryofib system
and that's the capability to monitor and
validate
the lamella production so what is meant
with that so um
currently you can either use a light
microscope to select sites where you
want to mill
but now since we have the system
combined in one system we can also use
the light microscope to inspect
or monitor the meta production process
so you can create a lamella and once you
have a finished little matter you can
basically
verify whether the target the
fluorescently marked
target is contained within that lamella
that's
also quite an interesting for automation
options
as i've shown before for all the term
kaio software you could
automate the lamellar milling process
and then later use this integrated light
microscope
to verify which of the lamellas contain
the target
so let's take a more detailed look of
the iflm optical module for the aquidos
2.
the iflm is a wide field optical
solution
you can see the beam path here on the
left hand side
it features an led illumination source
with four excitation bands which are
compatible with the most common
uh used fluorophores we couple in the
beam
into the high vacuum chamber of the
acura through a special vacuum
uh compatible window here and inside the
aquidos high vacuum chamber we then have
the objective this objective
is connected to a piezo which allows us
to do the focusing
on the crit there's also a special
shuttle available so that we can image
the sample on the code stage and then on
the emission path basically light goes
through the dichroic
passes the emission filter here and goes
to the detector
and the camera so we are currently in
the process of
finalizing the selection of both
objective and
camera with the goal to find here the
optimal choice between
both components quite important is also
that we
provide a range of dedicated aquados
shuttles for the light microscope so
there will be shuttles compatible with
liftout use case as well as outer grids
for the nz2 lamellar milling use case
and we also of course make sure that
this system is fully compatible to all
the
cryo accessories and features that i
showed you already earlier
one thing to mention here is for
instance is butter coder
so you need to make sure that this is
also still working and that's something
which we guarantee
on our system full compatibility
with the with the existing aquidos 2
system
let's take a look now at a few
application examples taken with the ifrm
system
first image shows you an overview of a
frozen grid here with
with cells on it you can see a lot of
cell clusters which are here visible on
the
grid you can also see some meshes on the
grid which contain
just the carbon foil now with the
capability
to have the light microscope integrated
into the fibsome system
we can literally turn on the light and
identify fluorescence on that grid
and that can actually help us then to
select regions which are suitable for
lamellar milling or even to select them
certain phenotypes based on the
fluorescence
thicker
this image shows you how we can utilize
the light microscope during the lamella
production process
so you can see an sem image here top
down view
over the mela that has been prepared so
this is still a course lamellar
and now while this lamella preparation
process
is underway we can actually check back
in
and see whether the targets are
contained in the lamella
by just turning on the light microscopy
information you can see that here
it can be easily overlaid with the
existing sem image
so that we can verify that a certain
target is also contained
within the lamella
one advantage in the lamellar production
is that we
physically thin the sample and thereby
we also eliminate a lot of autofocus
light that is intrinsic to the right
field system
you can see that on the right side side
here of the slide so you can see here
nuclei which are stained which light up
in the whitefit system
but as soon as we go to the area where
we have the meta prepared
we basically eliminate all that blur
from the
white field system because we physically
send the sample to
300 400 nanometers here which eliminates
the autofocus
light so that gives us a better
resolution
inside the sim-down regions and we can
also
use that information to overlay and
correlate and the light microscope
information falsely on the positionings
of the of the nuclei
the next image shows you another example
for the meta preparation where we can
benefit from the physical syn
thickness of the sample for the
fluorescence imaging
so we can also utilize here the contrast
which we
obtained by kaios license view imaging
so again here
this is a cryo contrast image which
reveals some
cellular structures to be contained in
this lamella so you can clearly see here
the nucleus has another one cut
and there are some cellular components
and we can now use the fluorescence
signal
to correlate what we see in this case
the
nucleus stained with a hook style
while the green signal here corresponds
to some mito tracker signal and we can
here see
some spots which are lighting up in
green which correspond to a
positive labeled mitochondria
on that lamella so that's the type of
signal
that we can obtain with the system from
synth lamellar samples
now the iflm will come with its own
imaging and control
software you can see a snapshot of the
interface here so that software doesn't
require an
offline pc to run so it's part of the
microscope pc
and it features all the functionality
that is required to
obtain fluorescence images there is a
way to
cycle back and forth between the sem fib
positions and the other position so that
you can basically
go back and forth between sem iron beam
imaging and the fluorescence imaging
positions
there is a control field where you can
adjust the focusing approach
and of course there is a field where you
can basically select the expectation
lines
and adjust the illumination parameters
there will be also a histogram where you
can adjust the different channel
information so that's all integrated
into this user interface
of the light microscope software
information that is taken at a given
position
with the light microscope contains
coordinate information that can be later
imported also into map software
which facilitates the correlation
between the light microscopy
and the sem signal
i mentioned it already before there's
also a dedicated
cryo shuttle coming with the iflm
microscope
you can see an image here on the right
hand side
this shuttle is optimized on the
pre-tilt angle for imaging
for perpendicular imaging of autogrids
with the system
and the other important thing on the
cairo shuttle is that it has to be of
course fully compatible
uh with the other use cases and features
of the aquidos ii system
i mentioned before the the retractable
sputter coder
for instance so this is a quite
essential thing to have
a shuttle that is fully compatible with
all the existing
features on the aquidos 2 system
beside the ability to do fluorescence
imaging with the iflm
we can also do reflection imaging mode
with the system
so you can see that on the top row panel
here so um
this is all images which are taken with
the iflm
while the lower panel here is taken with
the
sem so these are sem images and the
reflection imaging capabilities
are quite important in order to find a
line and correlate
images from the light microscope to
existing sem signal it can be quite
difficult if you have a sparse
fluorescent signal to
properly correlate it and in this case
you can use a
reflection signal to make sure that the
signal can be
uh well aligned with sem
imaging signals
so here's the lamella i showed
previously and we basically used the
reflection imaging signal to correlate
the fluorescence with the cluster of
cells from which we prepared that
lamella you can see that here this is
the iron beam image
showing the cluster of cells this is the
corresponding
fluorescence image which has been
aligned with the help of the
reflections image here you can see quite
a lot of details in the reflection
imaging here on the on the grid surface
you can even notice here in the lamella
there's always a small part of the
residual
carbon foil remaining in it which lights
up here in the reflection
signal and from that laminator that's
basically the images i showed before
this again shows then the overlay of the
fluorescence signal
from the final prepared lumeta
so the challenge for all correlative
microscopy techniques
in the cryo field are to guide the
lamellar milling process as precise as
possible
ideally you really want to know the
exact localization of
a highlighted feature of interest within
your cell and prepare the meta from that
now that's a challenge there have been
some ways proposed how to overcome that
fiduciary-based correlation is a way to
increase the targeting accuracy in both
wide field and confocal microscopy but
of course we also have to live with the
fact that the resolution that we get in
cryo microscopy and cryolite microscopy
is usually not sufficient to to target
within the volumes
that we need for cryo-electro microscopy
nevertheless there are approaches
available and i think
there are two things which are important
here on the integrated light microscope
we have the option with that system to
of course monitor this process
and we can either use a fiducial based
correlation technique
or simple 3d transformation to become
better in the
targeting of features inside the cells
so this slide shows you a very simple
way
basically to correlate signal when
when it comes to cellular imaging
when we have a sufficiently large
cellular object where we can
take with a focal stack basically some
information about the height of the
feature of interest then we can use that
information
to adjust the transformation in the ion
beam image
so that works relatively simple you take
a reference point
and the distances to your feature of
interest in the sem view the sem view is
the top down view
it's the same view that you will also
get with integrated
fluorescence light microscope from the
iflm you can take the z-stack
information from the focus series
and based on these two informations of
the z-stick information
and the position of your feature of
interest you can basically target
or kind of estimate where you have to
target um the other meta so that gives
you a positioning
information which which you can apply to
the iron beam image and then
prepare the lamellar milling process
so the advantage of having an integrated
light microscope on board
the aquidos 2 system is that we can
monitor this lamellar creation process
and verify whether a certain feature
is still contained within the lamella
that we are targeting
so here's an example how that could look
like again you take the sem top-down
view here of a cluster of cells you can
see them
here on the carbon support film
you can overlay that information with
the fluorescence
signal information
and then basically select a certain
cluster
of mitochondria in this example here in
the vicinity of our nucleus
and you can take the distances as i
shown
before on the slide which will bring you
to an approximate positioning of the
milling boxes
and then you can start the milling
process
so now as you do the milling process you
have identified where you
where your feature will be where your
milling boxes should be and then you
start basically the milling process you
start with a course milling step where
you first remove
uh bulk quantity of the material around
it
leaving a rather thick coarse lamella
remaining
and then you can basically take the
fluorescence to see whether you are
still on track
with targeting your cellular features so
you see this cluster of cells here and
the
non-synth samples and then we kind of
start the course thinning of the sample
here so we have a
balcony which remains and we can use
this check back function of the light
microscope to see whether we are still
on track whether we still have the
feature
contained within that corsa meta and as
we physically go
more thin towards the final polishing of
the lamella reaching 240 nanometers in
that
case here we can still verify in the end
that we have the feature contained in
the lamella
so that's something which wouldn't be
possible with an external system because
it would involve a lot of
going back and forth between a light
microscope an external one
and aquidos cryofib system so that's a
clear advantage of having a system
integrated into the cryofib
that you can do this inspection
validation
or monitoring of the lamellar production
process
so this is the final result of this
demonstration so on the left side you
can see the sem
image of the final lamella and on the
right hand side you can see the same
lamellar
transferred into the cryotm so on the
left side lamella we
initially targeted a cluster which was
here so we can overlay that information
with the fluorescence signal
and can still see that we contain a part
of this
structure which we initially targeted
and of course in the tm signal
we can then uh relocate this
feature again by again correlating the
fluorescence signal
which corresponds also nicely to some
structures
for instance like the labeled
mitochondria which are visible in the
t m the mela so that shows that
this approach is capable to
to target or guide us guide the
targeting process to the right spot
and shows also again the the versatility
of having a microscope on board the
aquidos 2 system
which can monitor and track this
preparation process
yeah with this i'm coming to the end of
my presentation
i hope i was able to share some insights
with you about
tomography and cryofib sample
preparation
i also hope that you were able to see
the value
of this new light microscope that can be
added to the aqualos 2 system
i think it's a great system that will
really simplify the light to electron
correlation process
and i also hope i was able to show you a
bit how it can be used
to validate the fluorescence inside
lamellars
before during and after milling so um
yeah thanks again from eyesight for
attending this webinar
and i'm looking forward to your
questions thanks very much
the thermoscientific aqualos ii cryofib
with iflm
correlative system combines light and
electron microscopy into one instrument
in the system fluorescence data can be
overlaid on sem images
allowing a localization of fluorescently
labeled cells
with integrated fluorescence you can
monitor fibulin to ensure
cellular target regions are within the
final lamella
fluorescence integration gets rid of an
extra transfer step
making correlation between light and
electron microscopy
easier and faster search less
discover more illuminate your
cryotomography workflow with the power
of integrated fluorescence
in the aqualos ii cryofib
welcome back we hope you enjoyed the
oculus video while we transitioned to
our question answer session
let me start by saying thank you to alex
for your informative presentation
my name is leah lavery and i'll be
moderating the live q a portion of the
webinar
um if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay our first question alex
how thin do you need to make your
lamella for imaging
uh yeah thanks that's a good question so
um typically
such a lamella is 200 300 nanometers in
thickness um the thickness of this
depends on the the mean three parts that
you can
that you need to take into account when
imaging them with a for instance 300 kv
system on the other hand you also need
to make sure that the feature of
interest you are interested in kind of
is accommodated in that volume so
i think typical volumes are between 200
and 300 nanometers thickness
okay thank you our next question is is
the liftout manipulator
cooled by liquid nitrogen two
a good question it's not not actively
cooled by
liquid nitrogen it's it's taking plates
from uh
from inside the system from a cold sheet
which connect to the
tungsten needle so that we can keep the
needle at uh minus hundred
um i think 665 degrees celsius so that
we have a
cold needle that we can use for that
process
[Music]
okay thanks yes we had several questions
about the
the integrated slm so
the first question is um is photo
bleaching a problem
yeah this is also a good good question
so i mean there are two things here so
on on one hand um under kyle you you
benefit from
reduced photo bleaching rate so that's
an advantage
on the other hand we have the system
integrated into an uh
scanning addict from microscope so that
means if we scan the
the labeled sample or the fluorescent
sample with the sem
beam then we can deplete the
fluorescence so
that was also one of the motivations
where we
added a reflective imaging mode to this
system so we can use the reflective
imaging signal to basically correlate
surface details from the sample
okay um and is the iflm
limited to only to the oculus 2 or later
possible and is it possible to install
an already working apollo
1 first generation system
yeah the system is um made for the
aquadose 2 system so in that case you
would need to
go for an upgrade and to upgrade the one
to the two system
okay is it possible to use the
fluorescence microscopes
in the coincidence point or do you have
to move the stage from the quitter's
point to the image with fluorescence
this is also a very good question it
would be really nice to have it in the
in the same coincidence point that would
be the ideal situation
unfortunately with the current light
microscope objectives
that would collide with the position of
the pole piece and
the geometry in the system so we have to
move to an offline imaging position that
means the stage has to move in x y
uh for to the lem to the lm imaging
position
okay uh next question is uh could you
estimate the timing for one
of the iflm imaging check back cycle
of a typical lamella yeah the checkbox
basically works like
you do the milling and then you move to
this light microscopy imaging position
you kind of do you can save the
positions to go there
quickly and do the focusing and take an
image and then move back so that will
not take uh
very long so i don't have the time for
that in mind but um this is a way how
you can do it and that's also the idea
of that you can see the or monitor the
progress of lamellar
production i also want to say it's it's
not a guarantee that you always have the
feature
of interest in there right the thing i
showed on the way
you can use that for targeting for
estimating where feature of interest is
to mill down the sample and to kind of
um validate it with the system
is a way to do that so it's not a
guarantee that it always works
on the other hand it's it's also great
because it can help us to save some tm
time
even if it's not working then we know
that this lamellar site is not suitable
and we don't need to spend the time in
the tm to investigate it
okay great does the islm
focusing require a sample z position
change
can you repeat that question here i
didn't hear that one yes because
does the iflm focusing require a sample
position change in the z axis
now the focusing is not done with the
stage so the the focusing is done with a
piezo uh objective twice so the
objective is moved
to uh to do the focusing and also to do
uh to record for instance the focus
stack
in the software okay
thank you the next question is to
facilitate the correlation
between the light microscopy and sem
images
are there predefined positions similar
to mapping position for acquiring lm and
scm images
or do we need to rotate the stage
manually
to take the images then align the lm
and en images
now there are predefined positions so
that allow you to go
back and forth from sem flip positions
to the
lm positions so um that's kind of taking
into the
the idea of the system that you can go
back and forth to this position so
similar like we have positions for the
sputter coating or for the
lift out procedures um so these
positions are kind of saved and you can
basically cycle
back and forth between the two positions
then in this case
okay thanks next question is um
reflection mapping is often used to
compute fake
surface profiles to a sense sample
topology
potentially useful to find spots for
lamella imaging
or milli any idea whether this can be
done with the islam
yeah i mentioned it before so and also
show it on one of the images
there is a reflection imaging mode of
the system where you can take these
images so in
in theory you you won't need the
electron beam
to localize and correlated information
back so you can do that with this
information which comes from the from
the reflective imaging mode
it's quite convenient and it shows
actually what supplies quite a high
amount of surface details that can be
used and to correlate the signal back
okay um another question is kind of
going back to
um ion beam and the milling were the
images labeled ion made with a second
electron beam integrated with the gallon
gallium beam source
both images um the electron images as
well as the ion images they
are detected with some secondary
electrons so the secondary electron
detector is um
detecting the signal here the
beam has a different geometry or looks
perpendicular onto the sample
and the ion beam looks under an angle on
the cleansing angle of the sample
but the way these images are computed is
purely by the secondary electron
detector
okay um let's try that
so i think we still have quite a few
questions about the ifl so
kind of go back to some of those
questions um
for the fluorescent signal how intense
does it have to
be to be visible in the iflm would you
be able to spot a labeled trimer
yeah this is a good question i mean
ideally of course we would like to have
a
you know the best possible a on the
other hand we also know in
in kaio we cannot use uh immersion
optics which would give us that high n a
above one
um it wouldn't work also in an in a high
vacuum system like in an
integrated flip sum system um
so i think the n a can give us um yeah i
mean
some not the best resolution possible of
course as we would have with the
immersion lens
it's also kind of a compromise you have
to do between the the working distances
and the selection for instance of the
lens um you can go very narrow of course
also with objectives that have that have
an
a below one but there are some
limitations also at some point and the
limitations come for instance from the
uh the radiation heat that could come
from the objective
when it's really close to the sample
which could be an issue
the other thing is just some physical
limitations because the sample itself is
typically hold within an outer grid
carrier
so that's kind of the the loading system
for the cryos also
so that has some limited height um and
then on top of that
auto kit is also clamped by just a clamp
or spring loader something like this
so which is kind of holding it in place
and that kind of ultimately also
brings some limitations to the to the
minimum
working distance that you can use so you
have to really
look at this holistically so it's kind
of that it's also working with all the
the use cases in the system that it's
still practical with foreign
and the other use cases that i mentioned
before
okay thanks um another question is um
are there any benefits of having an
external and
integrated cryo lm
yeah this is a this is actually a good
question so um
i think there are still benefits in
having both systems and
as you know we also worked with
schleicher together on a clam
shuttle which allows to carry the
samples
inside the fib after imaging them and
the leica clam system
so i think there are still a benefit
also using information from the external
systems
the ifrm is extending the i think the
versatility of the whole workflow by
giving the capability to inspect the
samples also in the
in the fibs them so what that means from
this um
uh yeah you know there are various
flavors of external prior light
microscopes
um also confocal systems or advanced
imaging systems so you can use them of
course to do other things than you could
do with such a wide field system
but for instance you could if you think
about the hpf samples that's
uh very challenging samples they are
thick they are very hard to correlate
so you could take information for
instance from such an hpf um
sample from an external light microscope
then go into the acrylics use this
iflm to basically correlate that
information back and this is simply not
possible before and
it's a challenge to do that on such
larger complex samples
and that could be for instance a use
case where both systems
really are useful okay great
uh next question uh can the resulting
lamellar grids be transferred to other
electron microscopes
to achieve higher resolution
i'm not 100 sure what the question means
of course the goat of that
ideas um to produce a thin sample which
is then
going to a transmission electron
microscope so that we can actually take
a tomokram which is then giving us a
much higher resolution of course so the
ideas tend to
to have a certain snapshot of a frozen
hydrated
native cell captured in that lamella to
analyze it then with tomography later on
okay um i think we have time for
one last question um there's a question
about um kind of the ice
or the objective um can the objectives
be customizable
yeah that's that's also a good good
question so
um it's not impossible to change the
objective but we haven't
really foreseen it and there's also a
reason
because it has an impact on the on the
entire system so that means for instance
on the focusing positions on the shuttle
on the
on the working distances the safe moves
within the system
we have to use it also for for other
applications as you saw before
so the idea is really to come up with a
solution that is
fully compatible with the with the
acrylics too and that will be also
guiding our
choice of the objective okay
um i think i will try to sneak one more
question given the time
uh does the have these stack imaging
and can we get a projected image
there is objective piezo it's possible
to also record some
limited set stack information that can
be also used for further processing so
that's
possible okay
i think that is all the time we have
today um i want to thank you again alex
and to all of you for joining us today
and for asking your interesting
questions
questions that we do not have time for
today and those submitted during
our on-demand pay will be addressed via
the contact information you provide at
the time of registration
if you are a current customer and would
like more information
please contact your account manager and
please use the contact us form online
at thermofisher.com forward slash
aquilos
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you share this email with
your colleagues
who have may have missed today's live
event
please join us again on june 24th for
our next webinar
in our thermo fisher electron microscopy
monthly series on labyrinths
on structural oncology fighting cancer
with cardia
the registration page is open until next
time
goodbye bye bye